no hay tregua navideña para las
pandillas en El Salvador el gobierno del
país centroamericano ordenó acercar un
barrio Popular en la capital San
Salvador conocido por narcotráfico
terrorismo y presencia de pandillas sin
remover un solo elemento del cerco de
sollopango más de 1000 soldados y 130
agentes de la policía extraerán a los
criminales que aún quedan en esta
comunidad famosa por el narcotráfico en
marzo de 2022 El Congreso aprobó un
régimen de excepción que ha sido
ampliado nueve veces y que le permite al
gobierno realizar medidas que apoyen la
polémica propuesta de bukele con la cual
pretende acabar con el terrorismo al fin
de su mandato según cifras oficiales el
plan ha dejado a más de 58.000
integrantes de estructuras terroristas
capturados y reportes de Cero homicidios
en el país mientras que organizaciones
internacionales denuncian que el régimen
de excepción suspende derechos
constitucionales y va en contra de los
Derechos Humanos después de reportar
torturas y malos tratos pero el gobierno
defiende sus medidas
esta comunidad ha sido estigmatizada por
más de 40 años
se dedicaron a distribuir y vender droga
desde esta comunidad el régimen de
excepción está contemplado para hacer
temporal sin embargo el presidente
bukele le ha dado un carácter indefinido
que parece estar lejos de su fin